[Music]
while go I invented something that I
called anti foundationalist theory hope
this is the idea that if we realized
that the search for foundations is never
going to use a pragmatist term cash out
, therefore and I what I've always said
is nothing can coherently follow that
therefore so that my quarrel if it is a
quarrel with Hilary has to do with why
he thinks he has to say any of the
things that he's just said for instance
if he says we give up on the idea of
that the world is anything in particular
okay and then the next sentence he
utters is think of it as open well if
it's nothing in particular and it's open
why do we have to think of it as open
its openness will take care of itself or
to put it another way giving up I'm
asking him to give up on the idea that
giving up on the idea that the world is
anything in particular gets us anywhere
and that's in general a subset of my
argument I've been making for years is
that philosophy doesn't matter it's a
nice game that you play in the seminar
but why don't you leave the philosophy
seminar and go out into the world that
are confronted with tasks and issues
nothing that you have learned or
unlearned in that seminar will matter in
the slightest
[Laughter]
you know time it you gotta respond to
why you say what you say and also that
philosophy doesn't matter I mean that's
official
and let's do white why you say what you
say so it seemed to me you know why I
have a go at trying to provide an
underlying account rather than just sort
of getting on with things
yes well my my version of that would be
that we build all sorts of ways of
understanding the world and all sorts of
closures as I would describe them in
order to be able to intervene and and
part of that exercise is to try also and
provide a general account of what's
going on for us in a way I think we
can't avoid having a general account
deed this would be my criticism of Vic
and Stein and of Derrida were later
figures showing dureena is that I think
we need that overall account to try and
make sense of what's going on and we
build one whether we like it or not we
choose some way of understanding what's
happening to us so the idea that we can
deal with a sort of non foundationalism
just by avoiding the topic which is sort
of it continue later Vic in trinium
position or a der ideon position that we
deconstruct everything we've last said
just seems to me to leave us all in a
situation where were profoundly lost
instead I think that we have to grapple
with the idea of trying to provide an
overall account which nevertheless is
not foundational and we want we need
that overall account just to make sense
of our lives I mean why don't you say
well you know you can leave all of this
philosophy stuff in in the library sort
of thing and just get on there life
I think we're all we're all in situation
of trying to make sense of what we're up
to what are we doing what's our what's
our what's our raise on debt and we need
that framework and I think we should be
trying to make that framework while at
the same time recognizing that it's it's
not the ultimate one it's a way of
holding the world
for all that I'd admire about you Hilary
I'm so disappointed to find that after
all you're still a theorist for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you